(Yee)
Yee
Why is that out of...
Wait... What the fuck is this ?
Yee Pewdiepie's...
(Yee Ya Yee)
No
Ainsley
(Yee Ya Yee)
Ainsley !
Ainsley !!!!
(Yee Ya Yee)
Oh my god it keeps going
Jesus Christ
You guys are fucking weird
Let's move on to what I really wanna talk about today
Unlicensed PewDiePie merchandise
Why do I keep f.. What is this
It plagues the internet
Every meet up I make.. I go to
I se.. I see you wearing the shirts
But i'm like that ain't my shirt
I found the answer
Fucking Ebay
They're everywhere
I have nothing to do with these... T-shirts
Although, They look really cool
I like the style with the .. With the sleeves
Is that .. Is that like a thing you do now ?
I guess that if it's on a PewDiePie shirt it must be cool right ?
You fucking stole my fucking name and likeness
I've trademarked PewDiePie , Alright ?
I could sue the shit outta you
Ain't no party like like a PewDiePie party shirt
43 SOLD OF THESE !
What the fuck is wrong with you !?
Oh Oh, They are reselling my book
They are reselling my book !
How dare you !?
And this is just one of many
Oh god !
Internet youtube xbox playstation wii gamer inspired T-shirt
At least can you make them decent
This one doesn't even say how many who bought this
Look at the eyes they are not
It's the shittiest drawing I've seen in my life
What the fuck !
The PewDiePie handbook
Oh there is only 2 available
Who doesn't wanna spend 52 Pounds
"But I don't know how much that is PewDiePie"
60... almost 70 bucks!
Julia Be.. Beasley
What is in it ?
What is in this book ?
What in.. What possibly would you need to know about PewDie fucking Pie videos ?
Jesus Christ
I give up okay ?
I'm just gonna sit here
...
So lonely without Ainsley :(
Oooooooooh Wow
The 27 Success Facts
Everything you need to know about PewDiePie "Franci"
Who the fuck is "Franci" ?
Whenever I think Of PewDiePie
I think of an apple in front of a book
I've seen these for sure
If you have on of these in your closet
I want you to take it out
Put it on the outside
Put gasoline on that shit
And burn it !
And don't burn yourself and sue me
Hey look at these ba..
Oh look at those .. Wow
I will take 6
Okay
Honest to god If you see..
Oh 25 sold
If you find one of the 25 people who bought snapped hat
And you happen to have a gun on you...
Please resist from shooting them .. In the neck
Oh he.. Oh they really stuck with this one
Who doesn't want a pencil case
A fantastic gift idea
*He likes it*
Fucking pencil case
Oh wow look at these hot guys
You can be one of them
Wearing a tank top
Like look at that
Look like the shittiest fucking shit
HEEEEY! THERE IT IS !
I actually want one of those
Oh I can get .. A mini one
That's pretty cool
Oooh who doesn't want a customized PewDiePie pillow with your name on it
I mean I would love to have one.. Sit on PewDiePie
You wanna sit on PewDiePie ?
That is a great image
Zoella looks fantastic
Oh my god ! You can get a replica Play Button
I will get one .. One in blue
That's pretty cool
Now I can finally replace the shitty one YouTube sent me
That's awesome !
For only 65 bucks
A Call of Duty Professional/YouTubers signed hoodie
For only.. 4000$
Oh Wow !
Who do we have here?
Of course we have...
Is that Keem !?
Is that Keemstar ?
That's ...
That's Keem...
Keemstar !
A keemstar signed hoodie
Ooooooh myyyy god
Take all my money
I AM BUYING THIS SHIT
Who doesn't want .. That !?
Nooo...
*desperation*
Red Bubble
Notoriously famous website for selling a bunch of unlicensed merch
I bought a thing there once
And it was the shittiest quality
I couldn't like even wear it once
Aaaah .. But I really appreciate the fact that if you search PewDiePie and scroll down
This picture comes up
Because I would rather buy this
Than any of that other fucking shit
Hey you can get it as a baseball sleeve
That's .. I mean that looks good right ?
That that that .. That looks real fucking nice, Doesn't it ?
My sig.. My driver license
From Gothenburg Sweden
Got my birth date and everything
I wonder if i use this one .. It would work
But this is the absolute fucking worse thing I've ever seen
This shit .. Uuuuugh
Broarmy .. Uuuugh
Oh god
Uuuuugh
Wait a minute
This is my merch
*barely cross-eyed pewds questioning his existence*
Uuuum
If you buy unlicensed PewDiePie merch
I don't really care that much
I just think it sucks because you get such a shitty product
I really wanna redo my merch
I want it to be something that not just you would wear but wanna wear
And I don't think that's..
That is definitely not the case here I think
Please if you want some PewDiePie merch
Let me know maybe you don't care
I don't care if you don't care
But i wanna make something cool
Uuuum
Because really merch is probably one of the thing.. Ways to support whoever you watch on YouTube
Aaaand aaaah
That's it for me for now
Don't buy any unlicensed merch
Even though I said I don't care, I do care
Please Do not , I don't wanna fucking see you
Ironically, Specially wearing it
Leave a like for more likes
And I will see Bros in the next video
Thanks so much for watching
And as always
Stay awesome bros
Nooooo.. Jimmy nooooo
Now it's time for father son bonding
BOND WITH ME JIMMY
It's the pizza
There's a lot of pizza
Great.
The pizza is aggressive
Oh shit !
"The pizza is aggressive" !
Oh shit.
Don't you just hate when your dad dies from an aggressive pizza
Just another day in the life of Jimmy Neutron